see you know I like dogs metella head so
this is black mirror Season 4 episode 5
and it is a little bit of a departure in
a number of realms to keep in mind
though I've only seen season 4 so far I
haven't seen the earlier stuff so how
much of a departure from stuff prior to
this I can't really say I'm not in a
position to and also spoiler warning
that's your heads up don't complain to
me so the black and white was an
interesting choice it was very stark and
I think it worked really well
visually for it because it just made the
whole thing just a little bit more
harrowing and also really kind of helped
immediately bring across the very
post-apocalyptic feel a bit a had a very
Logan feel to it a very the road feel to
it and I think that's a mood that black
and white serves really well I mean you
know I you can see edits of Logan redone
or you know sections of a redone in
black Hawaiian it looks phenomenal and
this feels in many ways like that so I
think that was a pretty neat choice this
is more or less a one-woman show because
it's just the the lead character just
trying to get away from this thing and
the tension ratchets up really really
well it this sort of thing you don't see
a ton of this whole just sort of
incredibly boiled down premise of robot
hunts human or just you know something
stalks human you know and only one not
like a group of them but just one you
see too much anymore I think it it was
used more you know a couple decades ago
usually by cheap movie stereo studios
were being completely honest because the
the fewer characters there are the few
people you have to pay but um it when
it's done right I mean you get stuff
like do
Steven Spielberg's first movie or some
of the better moments from the edge or
things like that and it it felt like a
throwback in a good way and and she does
a really good job of really exemplifying
just how stressed she is and and it
really is very straightforward there
isn't a ton to talk about in this one
which might lead to the fact that I get
the impression that this is not a
particularly well-liked episode I'm
judging that mainly on the IMDB rating
because I'm on IMDB and I do rate
individual episodes of TV shows that as
I go along and I did notice this one has
a notably lower user star rating and
then the other episodes this season so I
suspect that the fact that it is so
basic that it is so straightforward and
it doesn't really have a twist it
doesn't have a real deep examination of
much of anything really there's there's
stuff the margins there's hints at stuff
but the sort of the standard premise
that I've been getting off black mirror
up to this point which is let's really
examine what an advancement of this
understandable technology would look
like this doesn't feel like that it's my
I mean yeah the the design of the robot
you can see stuff like that like I
remember a year or so ago the videos
went viral of sort of this you know
four-legged walking robot thing and and
I really I really do like the design of
this robot I just like that it really
feels like it's built for efficiency
more than anything else it is no bigger
than it needs to be when it's in a
situation that it can't see an immediate
resolution to it goes into sleep mode
when it's had a pattern that it keeps
Realty nothing like white you know she
keeps hitting it was stuff from the tree
at regular intervals so that it just
starts ignoring her because it's a waste
of its energy to keep reawakening oh
it's nothing go back down I just I love
how it's just built for efficiency and
built for efficiency with with kill
people in mind and I do I do kind of
wonder and suspect though that sort of
the lack of full context or the lack of
really diving into the the notions of
the technology is probably why this this
seems to be a lower rated episode for my
part though I actually really enjoyed it
it was it doesn't have the lasting
impact of the the black mare episodes
that I've seen so far it's a more it's
it's very harrowing while you're
watching it but it doesn't linger it
doesn't occupy your thoughts afterwards
the way that something like krokodil
or even USS Callister would you know
those those have either concepts or push
characters such extremes that they kind
of burrow their way in the you find
yourself still thinking about it because
it it really horrified you or because
it's like the concepts were so
intriguing you keep thinking about them
and that's not really the case with this
one but I still actually quite enjoyed
it and and and feel that it was really
well executed for what it was trying to
be and I also think that the closing
note felt good and it felt right I kind
of saw it coming I figured that whatever
they were after was gonna turn out to be
something really innocuous and you know
it does I think it does actually paint a
pretty telling picture of whatever the
state of the world currently is that
people were willing to risk their lives
and in this case actually lose their
lives just for the chance to cheer up
what is implied to be a dying child and
the idea that they have to go through
this nightmare deadly scenario just to
get a friggin teddy bear like that
that's that's that is sort of the
sinking lee depressing implications that
you expect out of black mayor but here
it's much more background feature and
like i said the main story doesn't
the same kind of deep really dwelling on
it that I think a lot of the other ones
do so I think there is definitely some
heavy dark world implications to this
but they're but they're much more in the
background they're much more vague
though to my personal liking I like that
we don't really know what is going on
like on a global scale like why do so
many things seem abandoned is it because
of these machines or did the abandonment
happen you know because of something
else and these machines are just running
on automated for whatever it was that
they were designed to do but people who
might have been able to reprogram them
and calm them down aren't around anymore
like I don't know but ultimately for the
purposes of this story
it also doesn't matter and I think I
don't think that was really much of an
organic way to integrate that kind of
information into the story so personally
speaking I'm okay with the fact that we
don't get details onto why this is why
the worlds in the state that it is in
especially when it's depicted as well as
it seems to be and I think this one's
gonna be on the shore psychics like I
said they just there's there's just a
bit less depth to this and there's still
there's still plenty to think about if
you're a you know I want to piece
together the possibilities come up with
my own theory kind of person there's
still meat to get out of this you know
mileage to be had thinking about it
afterwards but if you're not that kind
of person
yeah it kind of just comes and goes and
most of the other I don't think any of
the other black mare episodes that I
watch really have been kind of like
theory fodder they've been pretty
straightforward like this is what we're
dealing with here
here you go so for something to to be
more visceral but have its deeper
implications be more hidden in more
background and less clear yeah it's it's
a change of pace and again I get why
it's probably lower right but I I still
rather enjoyed it
I suspect that it is probably an outlier
in terms of approach and tone and all of
that but I had fun
now at this one I've had very mixed
reports about whether or not I should
see all the earlier episodes before
seeing black Museum I had a lot of
people early on tell me I should because
there's a lot of references in Easter
eggs that I won't catch otherwise I've
had other people tell me that I really
don't have to and I can get to black
Museum now and you know maybe I'll
appreciate it more on a real watch later
but there's no reason to wait and at
this point I've just heard too much from
both sides I'm sticking with my original
plan from here I'm going back to the
beginning with a black mare I'm gonna
start with season 1 episode 1 I'm gonna
get through season 1 2 3 and then come
back and do the black Museum so I don't
have a timeframe on this right now I've
been trying to crank these out pretty
quickly but I think we're gonna go back
to something more in the neighborhood of
once a week I wanted to try and get
through as much of season four as I was
going to get through at a go fairly
quickly but at this point yeah I need to
slow down with this because I get hits
getting harder for me to schedule other
stuff in here so black mirror metalhead
what were your thoughts on it whatever
they were drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it do all the
things like can subscribe I've got an
email and podcasts and Twitter and all
that stuff
links for all those are down in the
description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]